bonjour et bienvenue dans quête d'europe
au menu de cette émission quatre
reportages tournés aux quatre coins de
l'europe par nos équipes d'envoyés
spéciaux sur lesquels nous avons
souhaité revenir du congé maternité en
grande bretagne en passant par
l'intégration des roms en roumanie ou
par la violence conjugale en finlande
qu'ont retenu une reporter de leur
enquête
que s'est il passé depuis leur première
diffusion nos envoyés spéciaux vous
faire part de leurs analyses du terrain
en attendant on part au portugal un des
pays les plus touchés par la crise
économique
bonjour son art bonjour n'aura vous
revenez donc de porto bassin industriel
du portugal et là bas vous avez
rencontré beaucoup de familles qui sont
guettés par la misère oui je suis allé
dans le nord du portugal où se trouve
donc la zone industrielle du pays se
trouvent les usines textile automobile
qui employait de nombreuses familles les
familles aujourd'hui au chômage qui en
plus sont victimes des plans de rigueur
successifs donc la conjonction plan de
rigueur et chômage font que ces familles
aujourd'hui ne savent plus du tout
comment joindre les deux bouts
en plus les prix au portugal augmentent
plus que dans le reste de l'union
européenne
donc ce sont des familles qui
aujourd'hui disent souvent qu'elles ont
une qualité de vie pire que sous l'ère
de salazar qui était la dictature il ya
trente ans on regarde notre reportage et
on se retrouve ensuite c'est le lieu le
plus connu de porto la rue
sainte-catherine et ses commerces
avec les soldes les clients sont
attendus pour compenser les mauvaises
ventes due à la crise
beaucoup de gens qui se promènent dix
personnes achètent les commerçants
souffrent certains cherchent à louer
d'autres ont fini par fermer à côté des
vitrines vides des enseignes comme celle
ci avec pignon sur rue apparaissent sur
chacune d'elles le même message
ici on achète votre or contre de
l'argent liquide
mario attire le client pour son patron
il dit n'avoir jamais vu ça c'est la fin
qui amène les gens d'ici ils viennent
vendre leurs bijoux de famille parfois
pour quelques dizaines d'euros pour
pouvoir manger ou payer le loyer parce
qu'ils n'ont plus de revenus dans la rue
il ya déjà sept magasins au portugal le
marché de l'or prospère
là où la plupart des familles sont
confrontées à des fins de mois
difficiles et loin du centre ville la
situation n'est guère meilleure
chaque matin clara amène ses trois
enfants prendre le petit déjeuner dans
ce centre social après des mois de
chômage et des allocations familiales
réduite
elle doit faire vivre sa famille avec
400 euros par mois
ce qu'ils mangent ici c'est déjà ça de
moins à dépenser pour moi le lait les
céréales que j'achète je les garde pour
le repas du soir je gagne peu une fois
qu'on a payé les charges
l'eau l'électricité il ne reste presque
rien je suis content de venir ici à la
maison on partait souvent son manger à
l'école avant l'aide ne s'adresser
qu'aux familles très précaire
aujourd'hui c'est la classe moyenne qui
vient frapper aux portes du centre
ces nouveaux pauvres survivent grâce à
la solidarité ce sont des familles qui
ont acheté leur maison qu'ils avaient un
emploi depuis des années
vie stable qui a basculé avec la crim
après avoir épuisé toutes leurs
économies ils arrivent ici en disant je
n'ai plus d'argent
je cherche un emploi tous les jours sans
rien trouver isabelle assure aussi les
trajets scolaires des enfants
tu as aimé ta ceinture aller certains
parents sans voiture profite du voyage
maria d'y trouver là un peu de réconfort
elle aussi a perdu son emploi envoyer
son enfant à l'école devient difficile
l'état ne nous donne que 30 euros dead
quand je vais à la librairie acheter un
livre pour monfils gens dépensent 25
sans compter le reste du matériel maria
attend les 16 ans de son fils qu'il
puisse quitter l'école et travailler
pour aider les foyers
cette route
isabelle la parcourt depuis 20 ans et le
paysage a bien changé
chaque jour elle traverse la zone
industrielle presque morte aujourd'hui
ici 80 % des entreprises ont fermé
celles qui ont survécu ont des mois de
salaires en retard
nous sommes à 40 km de porto dans la
région nord en plein coeur du bassin de
l'industrie portugaise des entreprises
mises en difficulté par la concurrence
internationale depuis quelques années
déjà avec la crise elles ont mis la clé
sous la porte
les fermetures qui ont provoqué le
chômage de milliers de personnes comme
manuel son entreprise a fermé sans
donner la moindre explication
aujourd'hui en procès avec son patron il
vient demander conseil au syndicat de
l'industrie automobile
le nombre de commandes a baissé de jour
en jour l'entreprise ne paient même plus
l'électricité alors on leur a coupé
on a arrêté de toucher nos salaires puis
ils nous ont envoyés au chômage
technique
quinze jours en avril dernier depuis on
n'est jamais retourné travailler
manuel gagné 475 euros par mois le
salaire minimum au portugal de la main
d'oeuvre pas chère qui aujourd'hui ne
trouve plus sa place sur le marché du
travail les entreprises qui créent des
produits à forte valeur ajoutée s'en
sortent aujourd'hui elles vendent même
mieux qu'avant
cette crise doit être une opportunité
pour restructurer notre économie nous
n'avons pas le choix
une restructuration qui prendra du temps
la dette se creuse depuis vingt ans les
comptes publics sont dans le rouge
et malgré les mesures de rigueur le
portugal devrait replonger en récession
cette année le programme d'austérité ne
résout pas les vrais problèmes de
l'économie portugaise
il permet seulement de réduire les
déficits publics
mais ils n'aident pas à régler le
problème d'une croissance en panne et du
manque de compétitivité du pays
à cela s'ajoute la faible qualification
de la population beaucoup de chômeurs
auront du mal à retrouver un emploi
manuel le sait il n'a aucun diplôme à
chaque porte à laquelle je frappe
j'essuie un refus les patrons ont
toujours une bonne raison pour ne pas
m'embaucher seule solution à ses yeux
quitter le pays
une décision qu'ils redoutent ils sont
déjà près de 120 milles pousser hors des
frontières par la crise dont sandra on
l'a vu dans votre reportage lors est un
symbole pour les portugais qu'est ce que
ça signifie pour eux de vendre leur or
oui les portugais ont toujours acheté
beaucoup d'or s'étant des pays d'europe
où l'on trouve le plus d'or est
aujourd'hui les portugais qui sont
amenés à vendre leur or c'est un peu un
geste de désespoir parce que ce sont des
bijoux de famille que l'on transmet de
génération en génération des bijoux que
l'on offre à chaque étape importante de
la vie et donc aujourd'hui vendre cet or
c'est vendre leur héritage et certains
m'ont même dit
c'est vendre mon âme est vous qui
connaissez bien ce pays qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus marqué durant ce tournage
c'est vrai que les portugais sont des
personnes en général très positive et là
je les ai sentis mine et qui sont très
préoccupés par la crise ils en parlent
beaucoup et ils disent être dans une
situation pire que sous la dictature de
salazar et beaucoup pensent à émigrer
certains l'ont même déjà fait beaucoup
d'entre eux et c'est une tradition des
migrations qui est qui reprend avec
cette crise et l'europe pour eux ça
n'est pas une solution
l'europe pour eux c'est assez loin c'est
les marchés financiers des marchés
financiers qu'on essaie de satisfaire
avec des plans de rigueur et ils se
sentent bernés les portugais parce qu'on
leur a promis en fait que ces plans
d'austérité allait empêcher
l'intervention du fmi et de l'union
européenne européenne et aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui se passe et donc c'est un
peu la double peine et ils le disent on
nous a pendant des mois
couper les aides sociales et aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui va se passer et donc la
confiance en la classe politique faibli
de plus en plus pour eux ce sont des
personnes corrompues vendu au marché
financier et ils savent que l'austérité
va se poursuivre donc plus de pauvreté
encore oui merci sandra merci n'aura ces
derniers mois l'actualité européenne a
été marquée par de nombreuses polémiques
en particulier celle qui a vu
s'affronter l'union européenne et la
france
en cause les expulsions de roms
bonjour marie mon genre vous vous êtes
rendu donc en pleine polémique entre la
france et l'union européenne à bucarest
pour rencontrer la communauté rom
oui je suis parti en roumanie non pas
pour rencontrer les roms qui avaient été
expulsés de france
mais pour interroger ce qu'ils vivent
l'idée c'était également voir si les
autorités roumaines met en oeuvre une
politique d'intégration
donc on regarde votre sujet et on s'en
parle ensuite à quelques mètres des
boutiques et des rues touristiques de la
capitale
en plein coeur de bucarest la famille
sous cac soit une maison abandonnée
quinze personnes au total qui survivent
uniquement grâce aux maigres revenus de
nicoletta la mer occasionnellement femme
de ménage
on en a rien à faire en roumanie chez
nous on se moque d'eux et pourtant on
est roumain quand mon fils pas pour
trouver du boulot je parle pas de moi
qui suis vieille on embauche pas mon
fils on voit qu'ils exigent gagnent
alors il ne le reçoivent pas ici c'est
la race coup pourtant de l'argent et dz
il y en a les subventions européennes en
faveur des tsiganes se chiffrent en
dizaines de millions d'euros
lohengrin craignent à bénéficie de
financements européens pour notamment
mettre en oeuvre des projets d'insertion
professionnelle pour son président la
principale difficulté
la lourdeur administrative non approuvés
par le problème ne vient pas du tout du
fait du manque de ressources financières
potentiellement il ya des milliards qui
circulent sur le marché
le problème c'est plutôt la bureaucratie
mise en place par la roumanie
du coup peu de projets aboutissent et
les résultats en matière d'intégration
sur le marché du travail sont médiocres
45% des roms en roumanie sont au chômage
les formation professionnelle dispensée
par l'association apparaissent alors
dérisoire face à la situation
ça ne sert à rien que nous on forme cent
mille personnes rome grâce au fonds de
l'union européenne si au final il n'y a
pas de boulot
la crise économique facteur aggravant
pour les roms déjà victime de
discrimination la roumanie pays
particulièrement touché par la crise
des dizaines de commerçants ont dû
mettre la clé sous la porte
les chantiers tournent au ralenti gilles
havas banlieue de bucarest quartier roll
christian 36 ans a suivi une formation
de cuisinier pendant trois mois grâce à
l'om j'ai une prime ya mais du travail
il n'en a toujours pas je ne pense pas
que la situation va évoluer
la crise économique est terrible ça
concerne tout le monde et gréau cas
c'est donc encore peur difficile pour
les roms de s'intégrer sur le marché du
travail
récemment j'ai travaillé de semaine dans
un hôtel bien beau joe ils m'ont dit que
j'avais volé un anorak en fin de match
et au courage ça a été encore un
prétexte pour mettre la barre haute
d'autres essais des fois que
en 2009 à l'issue de la formation
quatre personnes sur 100 ondes et des
embauches et constantin fait partie des
plus chanceux
moi j'ai eu de la chance j'ai trouvé du
travail
peut-être que j'ai un atout à la
différence des autres
voilà ma couleur de peau m'avantage et
du coup c'est cool chômage
discrimination pauvreté nombreux sont
ceux qui dénoncent inertie des autorités
vous même
c'est le cas de villy à moi et vice
président du parti rome je dirais que
l'intérêt de la roumanie pour les roms
est purement formelle nos dirigeants
font semblant de soutenir les politiques
d'intégration car cela donne une bonne
image de la roumanie
ça joue en sa faveur sont entrés futur
dans l'espace schengen on a proposé à
différentes entreprises d'intégrer les
roms à travers des programmes
c'est ce que nous disent les dirigeants
mais ce ne sont que des paroles
alors marie quelques mois après la
polémique s'est éteinte
qu'est ce qui a fondamentalement changé
depuis votre reportage pas à grand chose
en fait une fois les caméras et les
journalistes étrangers reparti la
polémique est vite retombé vous l'avez
dit
les roms qui avaient été expulsés de
france pour la plupart ils sont
retournés
sinon sur place il ya bien eu quelques
réunions d'affichage entre les autorités
européennes et les autorités roumaines
mais ça n'a été suivie ni d'actes ni de
décisions politiques fortes ni de
contrôles renforcés des subventions
accordées à la roumanie pour intégrer
les roms
en fait la décision la plus importante
ça a été le report de la de
l'intégration de la roumanie dans
l'espace effectivement en janvier
l'allemagne et la france sont
officiellement demandé le report de
l'entrée de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie dans l'espace schengen donc
cette espace de libre circulation en
europe puis en roumanie en fait on s'y
attendait cela n'a cela n'a surpris
personne ni les autorités romaines mis
les roumains cela n'a fait qu'aggraver
les relations déjà délétère entre la
france et la roumanie
puisqu'on considère que l'allemagne a
plutôt été suiveuse
influencé par la france officiellement
sur le papier un cette décision elle est
justifiée par la trop grande corruption
qui sévit en roumanie mais personne
n'est dupe on sait bien que la polémique
autour des roms a joué un rôle important
dans la prise de cette décision
affaire à suivre donc merci marie comme
vous venez de le voir l'europe a parfois
du mal à protéger ses citoyens et les
femmes sont souvent victimes elles aussi
d'inégalité de salaire d'inégalités de
carrière mais aussi de violence violence
conjugale viol harcèlement sexuel
quand on parle de violence conjugale on
cite souvent l'espagne comme le mauvais
élève
nous aurions pu nous rendre en espagne
pour réaliser ce reportage mais thomas
raguet a choisi la finlande
bonjour thomas
bonjour alors pourquoi avez vous choisi
de vous rendre en finlande mais tout
simplement parce que en regardant les
chiffres on s'est aperçu que la fal ont
été très mal classée c'est vrai qu'on
aurait pu aller en espagne en grèce mais
sont des pays où on s'attend plus à
aller quand on parle de violence
conjugale pas en finlande la finlande et
ma classe et par rapport à ses voisins
et ça nous a paru être un paradoxe dans
ce pays qui était précurseur en matière
de droits des femmes qui a accordé le
droit de vote en 1906 qui en termes de
parité n'a pas d'égal bah écoutez on
regarde notre reportage et on s'en
reparle ensuite
permanence des coudes pour femmes
j'écoute
bonsoir voyez que vous est-il arrivé
un appel dans la nuit finlandaise à
l'autre bout du fil une femme victime de
violence conjugale dans ce centre
d'appels anonymes des psychothérapeutes
comme anna lena se relaie pour
conseiller les victimes nous ne seront
pas autorisés à écouter la conversation
insultes menaces privation de liberté
dépendance financière
la violence est multiforme et bien
souvent elle devient physique
beaucoup de femmes qui subissent des
violences sexuelles craignent pour leur
fille ll ne savent pas jusqu'où leur
agressé avec un voile d'aléas
mais elles savent qu'elles évidence il
veut leur faire du mal
la finlande et ses six millions
d'habitants est un cas à part en europe
si les violences conjugales ne sont pas
supérieurs que chez ses voisins
le taux de mortalité lui il est deux
fois plus important en cause la forte
consommation d'alcool mais aussi un
manque de prise de conscience des
pouvoirs publics
traditionnellement en finlande l'état ne
s'occupe pas trop de vie privée
la priorité des travailleurs sociaux et
de protéger les victimes en les
dirigeant d'un des foyers spécialisés
comme celui ci caméras de surveillance
porte fermée à clé systématiquement tout
est fait pour rassurer et isoler les
clients comme on les appelle ici là nous
entrons dans le foyer
il se passe quelque chose ici on appuie
sur un bouton et la police est là en
quelques minutes
en 2009 près de 350 femmes et enfants
sont passés par ce foyer financé par la
ville
j'ai un journaliste avec moi il prend
des images mais je ne veux absolument
pas qu'il vous fig
là encore nous ne seront pas autorisés à
filmer les victimes
une règle absolue pour les préserver des
victimes qui après un séjour de deux
mois maximum retourne auprès de leurs
conjoints ou bien font le choix de
quitter le domicile conjugal
il est très courant aucune femme
retourne chez elle et que les violences
reprennent mais elle pourra revenir on
l'aidera autant de fois que vous pouvez
commencer une nouvelle vie une vie sans
violence pour le reste de votre vie
cela demande beaucoup de travail mais
c'est possible
selon carole à grône landes la spirale
de la violence s dans 60% des cas des
centres des coupes pour hommes violents
existe aussi
il travaille en lien étroit avec les
foyers pour femmes afin d'entrer en
contact avec les maris une particularité
finlandaise les animateurs des deux
organisations se rencontrent donc
souvent pour aborder les nouveaux cas
quel genre de violence y at-il eu des
violences physiques plutôt brutal
les histoires de jalousie ok rester en
contact sur ce dossier pour que ce test
à ce pool hausse animateur au centre
pour un violent ce travail croisé est
essentiel mais il est long et coûteux
et si la violence est passé à l' à la
maison il faut il faut traiter la femme
les enfants
l'homme aussi fort il faut essayer
de l'aider dans son processus de
changement et c'est alors il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent qui part un
coup financier
un coût social aussi le centre mise donc
sur la prévention et prévoit déjà une
campagne d'envergure au sein de l'armée
pour sensibiliser un maximum de jeunes
hommes finlandais au niveau national le
gouvernement a lancé récemment un plan
d'action contre les violences conjugales
avec pour objectif numéro un la
prévention mais pour mina pis pas la
responsable du projet il reste beaucoup
à faire pour faire évoluer les
mentalités dans ce pays qui a pris
conscience tardivement du problème et
cela nous aiderait beaucoup nous qui
travaillons contre les violences
conjugales en finlande
si nous avions des conventions
internationales ou des lois européennes
pour nous aider à travailler et à faire
pression sur les leaders et les faire
bouger davantage
cela nous serait utile 4 à 6 millions
d'euros annuels seront investis dans les
cinq prochaines années mais pour les
professionnels du secteur des lois plus
protectrices sont aussi nécessaires et
par conséquent un sursaut de la classe
politique finlandaise
donc thomas comme on a pu le voir à
l'instant dans votre reportage on ne
vous a pas permis de recueillir des
témoignages pendant votre enquête pour
quelles raisons c'est toujours très
difficile dans ce genre de reportage de
d'arriver à entendre les victimes mais
en finlande peut-être plus qu'ailleurs
parce que c'est un pays qui respecte
beaucoup la durée de la vie privée et
qui a le souci de protection des
victimes sont des personnes qui seront
en danger et qu'ils ont peur aux mêmes
qu'on reconnaisse un bracelet à un doigt
et qu' on puisse les repérer et que le
mari violent puisses te retrouver et
alors qu'est ce qui explique selon vous
cette violence en finlande alors il ya
plusieurs explications possibles une
historique qui n'est pas validée par
tous mais il faut savoir que la finlande
a été sous domination suédoise pendant
600 ans
et puis au 20e siècle a connu des
guerres quasiment de manière
ininterrompue ce qui fait que la
violence de cette guerre aurait rejailli
sur la société se serait transmise il ya
d'autres choses la consommation d'alcool
est très importante et il ya toujours ce
respect de la vie privée la société
interfèrent très peu dans la sphère
privée ce qui fait que ce qui se passe à
la maison il reste six qui est privé en
fait très doit rester privé comment
améliorer la situation
alors jeunesse finlandaise ne tolère pas
cette violence et si elle y est
confronté va très vite réagir là où
avant il y avait un sentiment de
culpabilité
et voilà on these un petit peu ça le
garder pour soi ça restait dans l'eau
dans le foyer donc le renouvellement des
générations et puis aussi l'europe
l'europe changer les choses puisque il
ya un projet de directive en tout cas un
rapport a été rendu qui conseille de
d'améliorer la protection des victimes
dans l'union européenne et la finlande
étant une très bonne élève de l'union
l'a toujours appliqué les consignes les
règles et directives
on peut s'attendre à ce qu'elles bougent
les choses fasse avancer les choses
si l'europe donne la direction merci
thomas les inégalités de traitement
c'est une question récurrente en europe
et s'il y a un dossier où les disparités
sont criantes d'un pays à l'autre c'est
bien celui du congé maternité et les
écarts diva nous en parler
bonjour élise bonjour non alors un
rapport a été voté au parlement européen
il prônait le passage du congé maternité
à 20 semaines payées à 100%
ce rapport a été très critiquée et pour
illustrer cette problématique vous vous
êtes rendu en angleterre alors pourquoi
l'angleterre mais il faut savoir qu'au
départ on avait choisi l'angleterre
parce que sur le papier la situation
avait l'air extrêmement favorable aux
femmes 52 semaines de congé maternité
possible c'est largement au-dessus de la
moyenne européenne qui se situe à peu
près à 20 semaines
mais une fois sur place on s'est rendu
compte que la situation n'était pas si
simple et surtout que le projet fait
d'effacer une très forte opposition très
bien m'a écouté on regarde notre
reportage et on se retrouve ensuite car
nice sur cette échographie la douze
semaines le terme de la grossesse et 19
novembre et je pars en congé maternité
le 5 novembre en gros ces deux semaines
avant comme ça je pourrais passer plus
de temps avec mon bébé comme pour louise
en grande bretagne le congé maternité
c'est presque toujours une équation
complexe car même si les anglaises ont
droit à 52 semaines
seuls les six premières sont
intégralement indemnisés ensuite tout se
passe entreprise par entreprise chacune
proposant des contrats plus ou moins
avantageux à ses salariés un régime à
deux vitesses que dénonce cette
militante socialiste française installée
à londres depuis dix ans c'est
discriminatoire entre les femmes parce
qu'effectivement il ya pas mal de
contrat qui prévoit des clauses plus
favorable donc finalement ça équivaut à
créer des statuts différents dans la
société et c'est vrai qu'il ya
enfin il ya des femmes qui sont très
avantagés par rapport à d'autres qui
souvent les moins qualifiés on ne
peuvent pas négocier un contrat plus
intéressant au niveau du congé maternité
s'arrêter pour s'occuper de son enfant
mais avec quels moyens ou retourner
travailler mais après combien de temps
un véritable casse tête face à un
système inégalitaire que les jeunes
mères de famille anglaise aimerait bien
voir changer à six semaines c'est très
court si vous n'êtes pas dans une
entreprise qui propose un beau contrat
pour la maternité vous êtes coincé et de
toute façon on n'est pas prêts à
retourner travailler après une si courte
période mais retourner travailler ce
n'est même pas toujours un bon calcul
très peu de places en crèche et pas de
maternelle gratuite comme en france
faire garder son enfant c'est aussi un
budget
cathy toker a repris le travail quand
son fils avait neuf mois elle a dû
s'organiser
je ne travaille pas lundi donc je
m'occupe de haydane et c'est aussi du
boulot on part aussi s'occupe de lui une
journée le mercredi et son grand père
c'est le mardi il va à la nurserie le
jeudi et le vendredi donc c'est un bon
rythme c'est juste qu'on ne pourrait pas
se payer plus de deux jours de leur
sueur et quand ça va et c'est que le
prix ses 77 euros par jour 650 euros
pour seulement deux jours par semaine
c'est un budget yade a pas de chef elle
est donc on ne peut pas trouver ailleurs
et oui chez lui c'est très cher
tellement cher que dans les faits les
trois quarts des jeunes mères prennent
les 52 semaines le maximum autorisé
même avec de maigres allocations c'est
toujours moins cher que de faire garder
son enfant alors augmenter le nombre de
semaines payées allégerait bien la
facture des jeunes foyers mais en
angleterre c'est l'entreprise qui payent
le congé maternité avant d'être
remboursées par l'état
une charge très lourde surtout pour les
plus petites d'entre elles 95% des
entreprises en grande bretagne sont de
petits employeurs et quelques milliers
seulement sont de très grosses
entreprises les grandes entreprises vont
être capables de gérer les changements
qu'entraînera cette réforme
mais les plus petites vont avoir de gros
problèmes et c'est pour cela que vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui sont opposés à
la réforme en grande bretagne plus que
dans d'autres pays européens
c'est parce qu'ici on a un très grand
nombre de toutes petites entreprises
si cela coûte cher aux entreprises cela
coûtera cher à l'état près de 3
milliards d'euros par an et en cette
période de restrictions budgétaires les
dirigeants britanniques s'y opposent
totalement la réforme serait aussi un
frein à l'emploi des femmes
mais sur ce sujet pour cet analyste
financière indépendante
il y à discussion sam bien sûr certaines
entreprises ne s'en sortiront pas et
certaines ou être tentés de discriminer
les femmes d'une certaine tranche d'âge
mais la question est est ce que ce sera
plus que la discrimination qui existe
déjà
c'est la grande inconnue c'est bien on
ne sait pas autre critique cette analyse
purement comptable ne tiendrait pas
compte des bénéfices de la réforme
par exemple si les femmes peuvent
allaiter leur enfant ce qu'elles feront
plus facilement si elle frappe à la
maison alors cela aura des bénéfices sur
leur santé et sur la santé de l'enfant
cela renforce le lien mère enfant ça va
améliorer le développement cognitif de
l'enfant et avoir un impact sur
l'éducation et des conséquences
positives sur l'économie dans une europe
vieillissante cette mesure doit
permettre de stimuler la natalité mais
ses effets ne vaudront que s'ils sont
accompagnés d'une vraie politique
d'accueil de la petite enfance
alors ellis qu'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis votre reportage
malheureusement le projet a été
abandonné en décembre les ministres des
affaires sociales et de l'emploi qui
sont en charge de ce dossier ont rejeté
le projet a une immense majorité et pour
quelle raison parce que ça coûtait trop
cher en fait clairement c'est des
questions de financement évidemment on
l'a vu dans le reportage en angleterre
certes il ya 52 semaines de congé
maternité possible il n'ya que les
quelques premières semaines qui sont
rémunérés à 100% donc faire passer à 20
semaines à 100% du salaire ça aurait
coûté quelque chose comme 3 milliards
d'euros à l'angleterre 2,6 milliards de
livres mais est ce que la raison
financière est la seule alors non
évidemment beaucoup de détracteurs du
projet ont aussi mis en avant le manque
de structures d'accueil de la petite
enfance
il disait augmenter le congé maternité
c'est bien mais s'il n'y a pas de
structure pour faire pour accueillir les
enfants et bien ça n'aide pas les femmes
et surtout aider à des prix raisonnables
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant eh bien il faut tout
recommencer
les parlementaires doivent se saisir
d'un nouveau projet a priori on
s'acheminerait vers 18 semaines de congé
maternité est a priori aussi on
renoncerait à une rémunération à 100 %
du salaire
merci à lise merci n'aura voilà c'est
fini pour ce premier tour d'europe
rendez vous sur publicsenat.fr pour
revoir cette émission et à bientôt pour
de nouvelles enquêtes